the town of India chill in northern
India sprawls on the banks of the river
Ganges here stands one of the most
important temples in India it's the main
temple of the Vindhya vicinity a
powerful Hindu goddess thousands throng
to this shrine but this is more than a
house of worship within the bustling
temple down a dim corridor is a tiny
locked room out of bounds to all but a
tormented few it's called the cave of
spirits a home for the dead and last
hope for the possessed
in the holy waters of the Ganges a man
and his helpers prepare for an arduous
task
Lakshmi camp Shukla is an exorcist a
pursuer of spirits and today you'll take
on some formidable foes families have
traveled many miles from all over
northern India to seek his help I have
four five lumps in my neck I get dizzy
sometimes my eyes roll up my neck turns
stiff but their woes appear to begin in
strikingly similar ways usually at
Twilight women walking down lonely roads
since an eerie presence they feel
themselves under attack
overnight something takes possession of
them some blame gods of the earth and
air others point to spirits of the Dead
no one is certain
well a lot of people here do say that
this is just superstitious those who
don't face this problem say it's
nonsense
those who suffer believe it's real Sally
kromm came with his 15 year old daughter
Moony for eight months Mooney has been
depressed and acting strangely she had a
stomach ache her eyes got blood-red she
starts talking nonsense whatever comes
into her head
Sally kromm and his wife of try doctors
now as a last resort they'll attempt
exorcism for Mooney and the other girls
the moment is at hand The Exorcist works
them into a trance
one by one the girls breakdown yep when
the spirit comes forth that a girl loses
all control over her body that's what I
know she has been possessed The Exorcist
urges the spirit to talk
it seems ready to surrender I will leave
her body will leave her forever the
spirit has agreed to leave but the
Exorcist must find it another home he
knows of only one place a place where he
can jail it for eternity the cave of
spirits but first he has to get Mooney
and the other young women and their
demons to the cave the dancing distracts
the spirits keeping them from bolting
the chamber doors are carefully opened
[Music]
the spirit that possesses muni responds
with a spasm of rage then leaves the
girl's body the Smashing of a coconut
signals the rituals end Mooney will
leave but the spirit that tormented her
will remain here forever
two days later the Exorcist makes a
house call to check on muni for this
family the exorcist extreme treatment
seems to have worked and they now count
themselves believers in the world of
spirits